morning hello hi hello
you got your prospective be happy we're
gonna go right back around and you get
into direct questions so start thinking
but but for almost four of you there's
one answer that's super important there
is no right next step and more
importantly back to Jerry's fun joke of
showing me the money I think one of the
most important things every single
person has to think about here and it's
you know it's funny when you said I
don't know which post it was about
gratitude and I when I said to myself
I'm like right because all of them are
something I'm really starting to
understand cuz you know again some of
you been following me longer than others
like a lot of these words gratitude or
empathy it took me a little while to
define them because I was just living as
a human making content and and really
not having the greatest vocab and being
a good student I also didn't even
necessarily put words to them and over
time whether I read a comment and who
knows why I got to the actual words that
help me frame them but no question in
that same process the thing that is
beating heavy in my mind and my heart
over the last three months and
especially over the last two or three
weeks is happiness over money in a real
way I mean it I really mean it and let
me explain what I mean by that you would
probably be shocked if you actually
understood how much money I leave on the
table consistently and have my whole
life you know it's one thing to say it
now when I make a lot of I get it but
you know again and some of you know this
like to go from 22 to 34 and never make
$100,000 a year and build a humongous
business for somebody else and then
leave at 34 years old and start from
zero vaynermedia started in a conference
room of another company because they
don't have money to have a more like
co-working didn't exist yet it would
have probably been will you work or some
like right it's super important for
several of you in a row really was aside
to like really hear me on this which is
there is no right answer there is no
right answer like if you're gonna do
real estate investment over Etsy because
it seems theoretically that there's more
money in it
but the two products you sell on Etsy
are like in your soul and you like it I
can rest assure that I can give you
tactics of how to build a Shopify store
and run Etsy and run ads on Facebook
that over time my belief is that when
you're laying in bed from you know
especially at five children everything
that's going on that 9:00 p.m. to 2:00
in the morning which is maybe your only
shot to like really put in like clean
time to execute against this if you're
not fired up about like searching on
Zillow or like talking to a Facebook
group about places or like emailing
somebody of like hey is that corner of
Michigan Street and is that a bit if
that doesn't excite you you're not gonna
have the energy to do that from 9:00 to
midnight versus if it excites you like
crazy of like your honey based facial
cream and you love it more than
everything you're gonna be in the
comments and replying to everybody and
so on a very serious note I really mean
this since a good you know normally I go
right into questions but I wanted to set
this up there is no right answer like
like like I never overthink my next step
vaynermedia might have been the wrong
answer k-swiss might have been the wrong
answer
empathy wines might have been the wrong
answer if you're asking the question of
what's the maximum use of your time for
money as a matter of fact actually let
me take a step back I know all of those
things are the wrong answer the right
answer in the way that people ask the
question here which is what's the right
business move to have maximized dollars
for me was to start a 500 million dollar
fund get paid 2% a bit each year just to
deploy the capital make one more right
guess in my career that looked like uber
Facebook Twitter nail it and make a
billion dollars on the back end of an
IPO of the next day or B&B or that was
the right thing for me to do in the way
you're asking the question the right
thing for me to do because I knew myself
as a human was to build vaynermedia
enjoy the process of building something
manage a thousand people because I like
feelings and people and all that that
was the right thing for me in the same
way that it was the right thing for AJ
to quit vaynermedia because he hated
managing people's feelings and this and
that and he likes the sports agency so I
mean this like and I mean it very
heavily I genuinely believe in changing
the world
impacting it and however you view it and
what the funnel that is we have to
change the conversation to happiness
over financial success it was like we
have to we have to and I mean that I
really really really genuinely mean it
and I'll tell you why back to giving
rings and giving and like and to wait
two more years like and me like listen
very carefully
the formula is basic if you're able to
disproportionately bring more value over
time you have unbelievable leverage and
if you choose to monetize it financially
great but if you don't and so you know
for example I've never scaled into
e-learning and things of that nature
because I'm not trying to maximize the
money and like recording one program and
then selling it for $49 I could sell 49
million of those I could and by the way
I'm not saying that you shouldn't it's
amazing you should do whatever you want
but in the answer of you should do what
the heck you want I think it's important
and let's take advantage of us being
here to be thoughtful about what
actually makes you tick what actually
makes you tick because I'll tell you
mean leaning in so heavy to what made me
tick continues to give me
disproportionate value to create
unprecedented wealth if I choose to if I
choose to and so I think I think that's
important and I think I think it's gonna
really play out for half this room
because you've already got certain
things that are successful on this and
then we're and then it's funny where I
just went which is that naturally segues
into what do you need the money for then
the other important part of this
question for everybody is how much does
your lifestyle cost and why you know I
don't you know like I'm you know I'm
really really fascinated by people
buying homes that have more rooms than
they need you know do they buy cars with
logos you know that logos that are
trying to impress somebody else like
what do you need and so I don't know I
really I do think that ironically the
floatier and
ideological and like warm and fuzzy and
chant like the more ridiculous this
sounds which is like hey like do nice
things and live is actually very real to
me and I believe in it mainly because
when you do it in today's environment
where it's being documented it allows
you to have an insurance policy if after
nine years of giving and living simply
you change your mind and you want to
have a boat and a friend mansion what
has happened during that time is you've
built up the leverage took you were not
gonna sell a million dollars what the
stuff two years ago I remember and so
what would have happened was he would
have started the process of monetizing
your audience which changes the dynamic
of you and your audience immediately you
know even the look at the meta version
of this I am uncomfortable to do this
myself with an audience I have to do it
in the framework of being on tour on a
speaking engagement because I don't want
to monetize my audience like my I love
when you say I wanted to give you
dollars back than what I said my head
yeah revs sharing with the partners on
tour and that makes me happy that's what
I want I very easily do not need to rev
sure with a tour or other people I could
send one post I mean like give me the
money come and hang out with me you'd
pay me more if I put in a setting that
was warm and fuzzy like coming to Wine
Library for today that's a bit more
excited like but that's not what I want
and so I really really really think it's
important like I don't think people get
stretched in uttering like like
Nashville nectars calm you like it you
like it you like it
I understand that's I do understand and
I don't think you have to narrow in and
like really choose like everybody pushes
this notion that if you don't go too
deep on something you're scattered
that's for them that is true for some
people some people are unable
incapable of juggling eight-balls
Michael juggle 34 because I like when
eight of them drop the people they're
telling you to focus on one thing they
can't deal with losses so when they do
two things
and one fails which is inevitable
because you're dispersing your energy
that's the way it is or the energy comes
from doing multiple things I get energy
from a random k-swiss meeting which that
helps me run vaynermedia vaynermedia
runs better because I have empathy and
baseball cards and the occasional Wine
Library call and being Gary via national
it helps it because I need that you know
escapism but still in the form of
business I use all these businesses the
way people use golf and skiing and
meditating do you understand that's me
and a lot of people are actually like
that it's called being an entrepreneur
you are kinetic and ridiculous and
random ideas and bouncing around and
over judging yourself that when you're
going to taste something else real quick
that you're losing focus over here you
shouldn't do that now what I'll tell you
is that all sounds fine and dandy if you
don't put use an arbitrary number eighty
percent of your energy on your core as
an entrepreneur then you might get you
know eleven six percents you know might
just be too much and you might not you
need something that grounds you and
supports it and it's back to Etsy and
you know real estate investing real
estate investing to your point with no
capital is a challenging game right you
can go spend your time and raise capital
from people right but you know one of
the reasons if you even just look at my
content evolution that I'm so interested
in Shopify or Etsy or going to thrift
stores and flipping is everybody's
spending all their time trying to raise
money because that's the thing to do and
I'm trying to teach people how to make
money so that they're not at the mercy
of people to raise money it's just gonna
take longer
I built a two hundred million dollar
business with vaynermedia we didn't
raise money start in the conference room
I limited my expenses
I didn't pay anybody think at first and
said I got you if you believe in me like
you know over time like so it's very you
know just kind of going around I think
that was a good starting point because I
think it changes the question and I
think it gives you time to really think
about it because there is no right for
who like right for who like and by the
way I do not judge maximizing financial
upside
I'm just wanting to make sure that you
know that's where your app is that where
you're at and I'll tell you what makes
that message different today than 30
years ago the internet people have to
understand this the practicality of
doing something as narrow as selling
raspberry jam was impossible you know
doing raspberry jam as your side hustle
after you worked at your mortgage
company at night in 1987 was impossible
you weren't gonna start a company like
that you weren't gonna be able to get
into Whole Foods or Shop Rite or
Albertsons it was impossible the
ridiculousness of the possible in an
Instagram and Shopify world of selling
your raspberry jam because you make it
at home then you ship it to 50
influencers and one posts it and starts
the process of awareness and the cost of
Shopify is nothing and like it's it's
very scary to me in a great way how
possible everything is with the internet
and that's why these kind of foofy
things that seemed way more foofy 40
years ago to me let alone to you know
are just not as foofy it's just not it's
not you can really do those things but
the question is you have to know what
you're up to you have to you have to
know what you're up to and you have to
know if it's like [ __ ] I've got to
provide for five children financially
well everybody's anybody here who needs
money faster is already in a more
dangerous spot it's just the way it is
right you know this from looking at like
it's it just it is right putting your
money into the lottery is mathematically
a bad investment you know like like
right like getting overfunded and the
burn rate this is what's happening to
every startup smart kids Stanford
Harvard they're raising too much capital
then the money burns and then they're
spending all their time trying to raise
more capital than I've build in a
business they're not spending time with
their customers that's what's happening
that's why it works
what guys it's very simple Amazon's the
biggest company in the world and and is
dominant because they're religious about
customers I am Who I am in the mark
because I am religious about you guys I
don't want anything from you I just want
you to tell me something good happened
from what I did for you that is the
fulfillment that feels better admiration
Overcash not super complicated and for
real not like 99% of people who say that
but then have a funnel on the backend to
have you pay them $4.99 a month and that
and I'm saying this because I want to
make sure you're hearing me probably
there's nothing wrong with that
just don't make pretend that's not what
you're doing if you're going to start
selling information own it don't act
that you're doing Jesus's work or you're
the greatest person but then on the back
end
pay me 739 a month right that's what
everybody does and that's why you don't
like them and that's why they're
different than me it's not super
complicated
that's why they're different right so
that's the framework let's use that
framework I don't have story let me give
you a very easy I mean this is as easy
of a question I'm gonna be asked as well
let me tell you why it's very personal
to me because everybody's got their own
version of it seven or eight years ago
it became clear to me that's something
in my communication style allowed me to
penetrate the mindset of fifteen to
twenty five-year-old alpha males in a
way that most people couldn't and the
majority of people that penetrate
fifteen to twenty five-year-old alpha
males sell them things that I don't
believe in and so I started having to
ask myself what does this mean and what
am I going to do about it because if you
really think about a lot of things that
now have manifested over the last three
years whether it's money to or many
other things it came to a head even
quicker than I thought and so the great
mistake that a lot of my friends who are
also passionate about this is they look
at other people not themselves and they
look at ideology not practicality what
can you do about it
you can put out content and be a
singular person you cannot ask others to
get on board you can only execute and
have them get on board spending your
time trying to convince others is the
greatest reason no good
never get accomplished I mean that it's
what's happening on every issue all that
you see on any issue that people don't
agree on veganism our country itself
right now race everything it's just
people trying to convince the other
person who doesn't think same way as
them it's a complete and utter waste of
time I don't try to convince the other
alphas that are selling jewelry and
girls and models and bottles and money
cash in the ear and this is I don't try
to convince those characters I just put
out my content and let us play it out
okay that's it the end but yeah I'll
tell you why and it's super important
it's super important because there is no
other alternative right yet you should
put out unlimited pieces of content no
no the the book and the nonprofit are
heavy and slow yeah
cut a piece of content that you post on
Instagram tomorrow is fast and light
your framework is heavy and slow and old
a book and a non-profit is gonna take
you a decade to even start the process
of anything tomorrow you can make a
singular video on YouTube that for some
reason strikes a chord most likely not
but you would then have another at-bat
the next day all for free I'm telling
you this is super important because when
people really have a passion around an
issue 99.99999% of people the way you
started your question and you framed it
is convincing others to get on board and
that never works what works is putting
out content and letting them come to you
nobody wants to be told no the end no
it's it so stop telling start putting
out content I don't tell other people
that are gonna be on this stage what to
do I talked to the audience and let them
decide that's how you impact that's how
you impact so I guess I mean because
that's not the approach that that I take
I actually show the stories of the
victims that are being great and so and
highlighting you know just like any
great what you need to make sure is that
you're preaching to the audience that
wants to hear it
not trying to convince the audience that
doesn't you know what's so unbelievably
crazy about this story I don't know if
there's a human walking around earth
right now who is more passionate about
people and less passionate about animals
than me let's talk about it for a second
it's really interesting like if you even
think about it i and i've burst this
around content sometimes I make the joke
of like I don't like dogs and then I
have to hedge it because I don't want
people to really take me literally but
it's interesting you have a framework up
these are our brothers and sisters I'm
like that's so amazing like I was
listening yet for me my great angst is I
cannot believe how people treat each
other but are willing to treat a cat
better than each other that's how I see
the world and I can tell you from how
busy I am and like how I roll like
you're not gonna convince me and I spend
time seeing guys who like I'm not gonna
convince them that not going to the club
and having a huge piece of jewelry so
they can hook up with a girl that they
think is pretty tonight like that's I'm
not gonna convince them at this moment
the end and so we need to get out of
convincing and changing people's minds
and we need to be tripling down on our
truths and let people come to us that is
a framework that will work for you
because it works for everybody else and
the other one doesn't
that's why nothing's that's why there's
so much tension in the system right now
in our country everybody's trying to
convince the other person they're wrong
without being empathetic to their
perspective I think they're both right
in different ways I don't think hate is
good but I also don't think I'd also you
know I was born in the Soviet Union I
also don't think like the government
should take care of everything for you
like I mean you know cuz the extreme you
know and what so I think you need to
really think about that it will work for
you because then you're bringing people
on board and then they're amplifying I'm
starting to see other people put out
interim content around gratitude and
empathy and kindness coming out of guys
that look nothing like you just couldn't
have imagined
right I might and I appreciate you were
your answer I think that once and that
word is very loaded so there's every
you'll appreciate this every words
loaded in that entrepreneur shines every
word slowed and entrepreneurship is
loaded no I mean this no but every word
every word is loaded veganism is loaded
every our country is now politicizing
everything so every word will be loaded
just get your head around it history
will tell you the future the 30s the 60s
we now live in a world where everything
is going to be politicized everything so
just everything's loaded that
documentary on Netflix loaded everybody
up in your world everybody now has an
opinion on it everything's loaded you
need to be careful though because first
of all I love that part
and I think again no different than what
he was doing I and you've heard this for
me I always tell people if you're in a
service give away the content for free
that will get you more customers not
last NFS with everybody like what are
you talking about I need somebody come
in like I can't I always tell people
tell them the secrets not to use you
yeah then many more people will use you
so I know it your your friends always
let me say one thing
pay attention to who's giving you advice
yeah if your friends have also built two
hundred million dollar businesses then
that's a valid argument you know what I
mean though that's what yeah that's what
I'm that I
I'm a little worried that your strategy
has a vulnerability which is the
real-estate thing is not gonna be so
easy and capital got it got it got it
got it faster is the single scariest
word ever for me in my life no no no no
no you do do you do mean it and this is
why I want you to listen to me it's
super important that is the scariest
word of all time and when when you have
five children two under the age of one
and a hat like I have a lot of empathy
I'm just telling you right now it's the
scariest world of all time and that's
why people go to real estate that's why
people go to cryptocurrency and cannabis
and sports betting and there's always a
flavor of the month you know buddy
social media experts are in 2009 2010
2011 I know mall now they're Bitcoin
experts now their cannabis experts now
they're sports they're chasin and what
I'm worried about is that you're chasing
faster dollars to siphon off your 40
hour we I get it it makes a lot of sense
I don't judge it I understand it I also
understand why it doesn't work for 99%
of people it may work for you but real
estate my sister got into real estate
because she was unfulfilled being a
stay-at-home mom even though we grew up
in an immigrant family we're like that
was the way you do it and I kept pushing
her and pushing her and pushing her she
was unhappy
she's never been happier right but her
first year or she thought she was gonna
be a big shot she thought she had Gary
vias her brother and he was gonna give
her awareness and I did and she was
gonna kill it she didn't sell one you
know not one and that put her in the
right mindset and now her last three
months have been completely different
because she stopped thinking about fast
so do real estate but sign up for not
selling one home for eighteen months and
then you've got a shot I'm telling you
right now there's no but oh yeah nothing
and I'll tell you why cuz I love you and
I want you to win any human that says
the word fast is indeed
and you said it at the end and so I
don't want to fight at it you don't want
to poke at it and real estate for a good
like two years before I walk away from
humanities being at Humana we're gonna
purchase a home that will have some
rental money coming in yep and so my
plan is to keep that money coming in and
once I get to a secure spot where I can
see here another rental property to keep
that money coming into that and finally
tell me about the two products real
quick you'll be over any cold or
anything and then the other one is black
asitane and so and really the only other
reason that that one's ever said is
something that's more handmade is
because that was quick and I'm basically
I'm just the middleman and that one so I
didn't have to create it like I do the
hell's berry where I cook it up and all
of that if I was your brother and we
were hanging out every hour I would
spend on the following spent as much
time just on the elderberry as possible
and spend as much time building that
business versus the real estate thing
because real estate has been growing for
11 years and there's inevitably gonna
soften and when it does you're in deep
because only the top 1% is gonna be ok
yeah elderberry is in perpetuity it's
your passion and I'd rather you spend
three and a half years building
elderberry than 18 months on real estate
and have you stay in Humana for three
and a half years instead of 18 months
because the next 50 years on the back
end would work better that is my
personal strategy one man's point of
view could be wrong but I couldn't be
more passionate about the advice I'm
giving you no different name by sy gave
her you know what I mean because again
the authenticity of you understanding
the elderberry thing is very real and
again to your point it's bless you and I
love how you said it the the other
product deviates a little bit from your
complete point of view but it was faster
on margin but it also already creates a
vulnerability to the purity of your
brand
yeah because I want to get so it's a
matter price that will be one thing
we'll be like so they'll be shea butter
in these things but everything for the
most part we'll have additional products
in it we're right now because that
athlete black spoke was something I was
able to quickly purchase and put up it
doesn't have the essential oils and
things infuse like I would like to get
it to so it's a I want to work on but
and what I'm worried about is when you
go put out a nice post and use the right
hashtags and and she comes in and looks
at your funnel that if you're beating
the drum of natural products and one of
your two products isn't all the way
there you've already compromised for
short term cash yeah you understand yeah
I just really believe what I'm saying I
really really do it's just it's just the
way it always is like it's the way it
always is and and it's hard to give the
you know I wish I was giving this advice
when I was living it from 22 to 34 you
know because when I think I say it now
they're like easy for you but you don't
understand what five kids run around in
my house you know like I get it like
people want to get to that next step I
you know I wanted to but I stayed the
course you know I wanted to get on to
that next that you know I'm a young man
who's ambitious you guys know me like
imagine what 27 year old me must have
been thinking about like wanting to get
to that next chapter like this is more
fun
so like my friends would tell me like
you're crazy you have no business being
in this room right now charging on a
credit card but you're gonna have to pay
off later but for me I knew the advice
that I could get here today could push
me so much farther let me try to figure
out for the night can you do me a favor
to get out of that little debt can you
give me one favor this is very weird but
I like hate the pressure of the debt on
this meeting this is very real scanning
items at Target and Walmart that are on
clearance that are sale selling for more
money on Amazon is an unbelievable way
to make $2,000 in 30 days that's right
which nope you can get them and and you
can go to those places late yeah like
like I'm notice how the device I gave
you was practical as [ __ ] like I'm
empathetic like I never like to give
ideological advice what place is open at
11:00 p.m.
Target what what could you know you know
I don't know who can watch the key I
don't know every detail but at least you
have a prayer if you want and I know
you're tired and people have the rest
like I get it all but at least you have
a prayer yeah and like that's that I
care about yep I got it I sense it
yeah you can you're capable
I got honestly I'll be honest with you I
can see it you're capable now let me
tell you something run the marathon cuz
you'll have a million dollar Elden merry
in business and be like I cannot believe
I have this you will I'm being scanned
by the way what I definitely can tell
you you'll definitely have one hundred
thirty seven thousand dollar profit
business around that one product I
genuinely believe that that's cool
you know but you have to go all-in on
that this is an example going all-in on
a thesis you know cool good good
listen um honestly I'm in the business
of affirmation yeah so when I started
this business at twenty four twenty five
years old ten years ago my parents were
like good luck I mean there was no help
there was nothing there
which is right which is right real quick
I just want to make this point mainly
this is now selfish because I want the
content okay cuz you helped me that's
right yes like all these people that
like are mad at their parents for not
helping like that that's more right than
wrong like you can't have it both ways
like kids are always like I got to start
a business again my parents won't let me
and like they'll let you move out and go
start a business what you're actually
saying is you don't want to go to
college and you want your parents to
give you that money so that you can
start a business and make your tenure an
entrepreneur and feel cool I love your
parents for that so the best thing they
did the thing it did for me was amazing
scrappy helium so in our industry
there's kind of a 50/50 split roughly
where half of them are franchises and
the others are independence and I'm an
independent and my motto
I mean internally to our businesses
franchises because I think they eat
people's lunch okay people are
struggling and giving up good money to
launch these things they could have done
on their own
I understand me dependents are getting
shot at but there's a big difference
between somebody who's an entrepreneur
and somebody who has entrepreneurial
tendencies and that's what franchisees
are built for yes franchisees are built
for people that have entrepreneurial
tendencies they are incapable in their
stomach to take the full risk of doing
it for themselves and that's okay the
same way I'm incapable of reading
I mean that by the way the amount of
time I waste having to do three-minute
calls because I'm not willing to read
the email my employee sent me is
remarkably high and so just keep that in
mind keep going so one of the things
that we figured out is I don't
necessarily want to attack the
franchise's I want to support the
independence and give them an that's
right for growth right and so there's no
voice that's actually leading them so
there's some national associations that
service everybody but they don't service
the independence alone so I want to
start an alliance and network nationally
my target is a pool of 12,000 companies
my goal is in the 10% so if I can get
10% of them a thousand and get them to
maybe follow and listen and do something
and then another 10% like a hundred that
we can impact deeply in some way
downstream so the first thing is I'm
starting a channel or this is where
we're very I have no fault go ahead it's
called elevate with good news everybody
has no followers at first we all start
with zero
yes so the channel the thought is
elevate with kanoon which we just let
let me give me an answer to no because
I've been listening to the first part
Ness I'm gonna be a very simple answer
this is a piece of cake for you if you
make one binary decision here which is
that you're a media company and that's
that you have to realize you're now CNN
and Fox and CNBC and Reuters and that's
it so what does that mean that means the
answer is gonna be yes to everything
that comes out of your mouth that's why
I cut off podcast mmm-hmm LinkedIn
content yep like you know my favorite
thing to say is watch what I do not what
I say the answer is what I'm doing yes
all of it email newsletter
uh-huh Twitter like all of it and yes
could lengthen be better based on your
business of course but what do you need
to do the answer is both you need to
become disproportionate better at
LinkedIn and you need to start the
process of your Facebook group you need
to start the process of your text
messaging platform you need to start the
process of your podcast now back to like
okay that's cute Gary but like come one
person like like how do I think about it
this is again an answer for everybody
right now to me the hot hot things our
podcast LinkedIn Instagram YouTube right
those things are over indexing for
different reasons now if you're selling
you know strawberry jam Instagram / link
that makes sense if you're doing b2b
LinkedIn over in
you got to be thoughtful but the answer
is you should challenge yourself to do
as many things as possible well and the
only other thing you have to do canoe is
be self-aware are you comfortable in
front of a camera is it better for you
to like I don't write like and I and and
I didn't force myself there's a reason
in 2004 to 2008 you don't see any
content for me that was the era of
blogging I can't write
no content for me YouTube comes along
got it and then I got to scale seven
years later where I could hire a writer
to transcribe my audio yeah audio is
absolutely winning right because the way
we roll we like to consume content
passively and when you're on the
treadmill listening to a podcast has now
become real right a lot a lot of people
watch my videos by just listening they
don't even watch it right there playing
YouTube in the background blasting it
like you know so yes audio and that's
what's fun right like radios back like
it all right yes audio is absolutely an
incredible place and I love it because
when video was dominating six years ago
a lot of people are conscious on film
like I mean 2011 to 2015 my life was
unbelievable women raising their hand
and saying Gary I don't want to do film
because like you don't get it we get
judged for our makeup I'm like cool I do
get it I get judged for being hyper
judgement is judgment yes they're
looking at your you know physique and
face and yes and for me they're saying
you're fully because that's your to high
energy you must be a scam artist that
doesn't feel nice for me well yeah I
mean like every like literally like all
sorts of things and I got very judged
for cursing into that like now there's
more cursing in content you should have
seen what I was going through in two
thousand eight and nine and ten like
completely dismissed like very heavily
judged you know
yeah but nobody knew that about Tony in
2009 10 11 right like I created a
framework for people allowing people to
be who they are I'm proud of that 100
percent so that's your answer bro
thank you I converted a room in my
basement I mean I'm talking to go all in
and convert into a studio but don't
listen to me do not be the guy who buys
all the best tennis equipment and loses
six love to somebody who's got a wooden
tennis racket where everybody goes as
they think it's the equipment 1,000
episodes of Wine Library TV and I wasn't
even Mike then I had no lighting 1000
didn't even know until the diva rocks
and the kaleb's and baboons and irises
came into my life about so I wouldn't
like your sitting on the pack I'm like I
don't give one last question I'm sorry
so this during your your kind of rise in
growth and all that you went from a
person doing these things to a brand
that's doing these things and the
challenge for me meaning I wanna make
sure I understand how your media or
carry me about Gary Vee and kind of the
channels and the podcasts at some point
you are a person right I'm still a
person wrong people and I mean
I think we manifest it in I think what
somebody's successful at it we just
start using a word like you've become a
brand right but I'm still a person yes
like I'm literally doing exactly the
same thing and just that the success
makes us look at it and try to analyze
it so the challenge I've got is you talk
about this a lot which is love your
community I mean you have to be more on
commenting on what they're talking about
on their posts yep really be part of
that yep and so I've been doing so much
of that as a individual my Facebook
account my LinkedIn account is there a
need to kind of shift to this it has to
be done under the elevate with canoe
page it has to be done under this other
no thing no as an effect I don't think
you necessarily have to create I don't
engage on the askgaryvee page even
though that's a show I think you do it
under canoe because you might want to
change it from elevate right but if you
want to change it in four years I think
you always lean in on your own human
page because Gary Vaynerchuk meant wine
guy to the world a decade ago and it
might mean sports car dealer in four
years going this way like no no I would
keep it on your page and and honestly
you don't what when you were talking I
was like smiling because I'm like hers
is so easy you're looking at everybody
else right now and that's your biggest
problem it anyway every single day
people copy every single thing I do
people literally take my content right
what I'm saying then make a four hundred
dollar ebook and run ads against my own
fans and sell to my fans and I spent
0.00 seconds on it you're getting caught
up in people who have four hundred
forty-seven thousand followers on
Instagram doing what you do and thinking
that they copied your and it's putting
you on defense
know is you know should I be doing my
own content should i yes or somebody to
do it because I've been hiring people to
do it and I feel like they're not
capturing that way so of course we're
not hard you know of course we're not
yes you should be doing it I believe
that doing social media work today is as
required for a business as knowing your
finances it's become too important its
marketing its marketing it's always been
important the problem now is everything
else is become a commodity communication
is growing in value information and like
the product itself is actually not that
it's declining but that you know you
have you out if you a product you'll
never win but communication is a
requirement and by the way there's a lot
of business owners you're looking at one
that's not deeply in or her or his
finances but I'm dangerous enough to not
get and I think everybody needs to be
dangerous enough in social media
marketing to not get which is why I keep
telling everybody you don't have fifty
hours to learn this but you're running a
business put in work learn it learn it
so when you hire somebody you can know
if Sally or Rick is doing a good job or
a bad job because you have at least you
actually understand that's why I want
everybody to put fifty hours of actual
work in every platform your whole
framework scares me I'm telling you I'm
in a good way in a good way I'm not
saying it's a bad thing you're spending
so much time on everybody else and
that's when I go into something like
this whether somebody puts on a credit
card for sure or anything else I'm
always I'm always like so passionate
about disproportionate bringing as much
value as possible I'm a fast read when
it comes to people and business I'm
telling you with my whole soul hot
committed your your framework right now
is a problem you're just spending all
your time thinking about like I've never
thought of who's coming up
you know like you're spending your time
on outside something is clearly hot like
you take so much pride I think which is
amazing in that you innovated and that
was a big part of your success and now
that that's been commoditized there's a
sense of anxiety that you want to
replicate that thing because you know
what that meant which is then forcing
you to look at the outside instead of
the inside the way you created and
innovated the first time was if you went
inside that's true I'm aware it's true I
believe you which is why I'm so
passionate to do what I do I think I I
think an enormous amount of people
desperately want to move from building a
business to giving advice to businesses
for people are here looking to do that
there's a lot of attractive reasons for
it but one of the things that scare me
is that a lot of people are not good at
giving advice like that you may or may
not be but I can tell you right now
you're getting awful advice because it's
not contextual your story super simple
you innovated by being insular and now
you're spending all your time looking
outward the second you go back to
actually hanging out with women and
talking about you is when you're gonna
invent your nose hair thing I'm being
serious
that's why your product was so good we
listened there's a reason I'm fresh and
different it's because I don't listen to
anybody else I only listen to the end
user I put out Compton I watch you you
like the blueberries post I think about
it a lot of people did and that was me
also taking another piece of my own
advice with my own self eating my own
dog food don't just put out content that
you know works try
I put out the blueberry post two weeks
earlier it was the wrestling post with
wale it was my worst performing post on
Instagram in three years
mmm is right
you understand it's such an embarrassing
for my hardest core fans I just said now
the blueberry thing makes like goes and
is my most successful post it was the
same exact thing that I posted two weeks
earlier with my wrestling post and
showed me in Boston with a sign one
destroyed it and gave me insights one
failed miserably little you I couldn't
have drawn it up better for my thesis of
trying my worst performing post in two
years my best performing post in two
years exactly the same thing I went
completely out of my lane of what you're
used to singing one was about wrestling
one was about blueberries the end you
have to go insular I believe I'm ready
to give up and I just don't know the
right advice to give him either to like
hang in there or it's like it's ripping
my heart out I'm not sure what to say to
him tell him to be happy
so if quitting College makes him happy
because he doesn't like the anxiety
that's bringing that's what he should do
I mean it like a college degree from
anywhere besides the top ten schools in
America today is ROI negative I know
what where's he go to school great you
think that Korea's gonna get him a job
that's like so dis the the end the end
so then what he's getting social skills
he can do that anywhere take the money
or give Delaware and go to Europe he'll
get real social skills you know
understand we have to change this
conversation you have to be okay with
what him dropping at a school means
amongst your circle brothers sisters
best friends pick your parents I don't
know your situation
and then you need to take that energy
and make him feel safe that's what
parents should be doing that's super
real but back to what his parents did so
well when he's not in school it's like
yo go Mama's not gonna take care of you
big boy go get a job at Toys R Us oh
they're not even around anymore go get a
job at Walmart you know start your
business you want to start your business
amazing you better live what's you
better live off-campus with your buddies
that are still in school and sleep on
their couch while you're hustling got it
he can quit but you can't enable the
next chapter but when he hears that
you'll open up his world let him be
happy but on his own two feet got it
that's what works you have to first get
good with your son dropped out of school
that's number one so we're parents
subconsciously again great I believe you
but you're not in control of that you
like you can't control that and I
promise I don't like to be absolute cuz
it's just unfair he's not gonna regret
it and more importantly what you want to
do is not give him any ammo to blame you
I believe you but like hear it because
it's important if you put it on him and
you create the framework and you support
him if you if you push him in either
direction at forty nine he gets to come
in and say you made me stay in college
then he's really lucky so just make sure
he knows that fully fully cuz 98% of
this conversation is just as bad as 50
you have to be a hundred got it got it
right that last 2% like any little hedge
I believe you because I can sense it but
it's a hundred
now we're so last year I got distracted
okay because of who I work with what I
do I walked away for a Idol I walked
away from another television show I
walked away from six videos all the jobs
I felt that I was starting to every time
I did focused on my stuff that
distraction would come along I
understand and I walked away from that
knowing that this year it's all focused
I understand that what I do the people
that I want to serve those are the
parents of these talented kids okay but
I don't want to ignore my independent
artists either artists need to
understand that they're not welfare kids
they want everything for free there is
the RV an artist they weren't on this
stuff so I need them to invest even if
it's just time is what I try to share
with that it's even if you're investing
your time that has value yep you know to
put a Taylor Swift stuff which I tell
people you should listen to me because
of her but you should ask what I can do
for you yeah it was ten years ago
yep you know this new relationship I
have with Gao and all these different
things that are coming into play house
the best way to use them to get the
conversation started but also let people
know don't expect those heterozygous I
think by just putting out the content so
I think what you know it's so funny if
you even think back to to earlier I
think we're all affected makes sense by
our life and like what's happened in the
past it's a framework you have this
ridiculous thing happened that is such a
big cosign that gives you such you know
a decade worth or seven years of like
instant credibility of like this is who
I was immediately i weirdly really think
then you reverse it I I put things like
me being an investor on Facebook and
Twitter and uber is in my Instagram
profile it's on my website but I never
talked about it for say unless I need it
contextually I think if you establish
your profiles it's really funny I
literally believe your bio on all your
profiles if you just nail it and create
context maybe even says you know I
started with if the Taylor Swift thing
right and it says you know you know
original or whatever it is and former
manager tell with a link that goes out
to an interview from seven years ago
great and then you're set what I do is I
put out super value and then if you're
like who the [ __ ] is this person and you
go into my profile
and you go into the places that creates
validation or creates rationale that's
what I think you need to do because
otherwise it's always in the air and
you're always trying to get it out you
know what I mean just put out thoughts
and content and things of that nature
and don't hedge or rationalize in every
piece of content or even having the
energy of if you feel great about how
your profiles are set up if you know if
little baby four years ago in Atlanta
sees that piece of content and he goes
to your profile the validation and the
reason sits there they'll find it if you
set it up within the profile that's how
I would do it people watch it I take
what he tells people to do and I show
how to do it which is what I absolutely
require your music last thing so how is
it that I can best put yourself in my
situation yep how is it that that's all
I ever do best
take a picture that you and I may take
here have a press release that goes out
about my podcast we have picked up a
company that shares this which because
people have referred to me they called
me in the music side view because of the
empathy and the solutions not because I
just yell at people the best ways for
you to email me and let me get context
on what galleries doing cuz that's under
my radar I have no idea and the number
one thing you don't want to do is over
hyperbolized the reality of it so for me
to give you an answer I need to
understand the context make sense then
we'll figure it out and then if it's
then there's a million ways to do it
right yesterday if you look at my social
we launched a new podcast called the CMO
podcasting gallery media group and I'm
giving a huge cosign so let's figure out
where it sits and yeah just what you
never look at the amount of people the
amount of business people that roll up
it to me at events and they're like hey
Gary can you hold my product and they
take a photo right and I'm happy to do
it but then I always say they're gonna
[ __ ] this up because they're gonna go
take it and make pretend I'm endorsing
the product it's a selfish act right
right like if we take
photo and it and there's any form of a
selfish act you're gonna be like forget
about if it works in the short term
you've lost in a long term because in
perpetuity I'm not gonna be happy about
it
got it so the answer is we need to
figure out what has happened with
gallery yeah I'm thrilled yeah you can
bro honestly you can use in perpetuity
you can make pretend that you built me I
don't care I mean it I don't care I'm
trying to give the advice that I think a
lot of people make a mistake on like the
merit of it like I mean I literally
watch people grab me in the airport we
take a photo I'm super pumped it feels
nice they're pumped but then I go into
my explore page like my tag page I look
and people write things like just
finished a big meeting with Gary B and
I'm like like they're gonna lose they're
gonna lose in life and I don't feel bad
I don't give a [ __ ] there is no
validation or justification of anything
I do I don't care if people are trying I
mean do many people use my image in ads
to sell their [ __ ] [ __ ] products
and I have a full legal team just on
that it's the same [ __ ] it's their same
that's it and it's why I gave the advice
to you like I want you to achieve your
goal and I believe that's the framework
that I've seen one man's point of view
so yeah we did hover out of order yeah
god again I know my opening rant was for
you do not justify creating a.com every
day of your life just do keep doing it
because I mean cuz it makes you happy I
just I get it I get it you're grateful I
yeah that's the work and say you know
this is about you you can say hey
everybody look at my client look at the
eyebrows so it's not you know what I
mean I'll help you get in front of a
camera it's easy I love it or maybe it's
not
or maybe it's self awareness and what's
easier is recording on your memos on
your phone when you have a thought and
you post that and I mean that I mean
it's super important you made that point
I click I agree with you like it's you
know this is one man's point of view
I'm trying to over-deliver on the best
thing that I can I have a lot of data at
this point a decade in so I think a lot
of these hot takes have validity to them
you know I in human truths and that's
why I said a lot of these things have
been easy for me but this is one big
game of self-awareness one big game of
self-awareness correct
you know I literally can't write an
article but I'm literally gonna go on
stage right now in front of like however
and people and have no clue what I'm
gonna say one minute before and destroy
it you know like everybody's got can't
sing Taylor can you know like so it's
important important that's the way to
think about so what's your question yes
yep yep yes yes I heard and the beers
come in I got it friends yep I
understand that's the big bet that's the
80% I got it that's the 80% that's your
Boehner I understand that I totally
understand this
- just hold me yep until they go to
college yes then I have something I
understand I don't want to lose it so
I'm willing to buy it here and I'm
willing to go ahead ever to grow it my
dream get an RV travel the country play
music for tips and gas I don't even care
[ __ ] love it if that's not true
you've won
I want to go into areas where recovery
is weak yep because I have a people have
told me this that I have an ability to
create a community because I I care
about forget it and I will buy them
groceries and spend time with them and
build an area and then it propagates and
I can move on luxury I get it so so to
me before you get to the question one of
things that's really running through my
mind is you need to make if your dream
is that simple and what you're holding
your breath for is another seven years
before the kids are in school I see that
make sure that if you've poured money
into this restaurant if it's not
successful that you don't allow it to
get you into debt because no joke I hear
you and no joke when I'm listening to
you
like straight up if this was before you
bought the restaurant I would have
literally told you like just sit on the
money because if you're telling me the
truth that your dream is to drive an RV
for tips and gas because you love it the
only vulnerability I see in you right
now is that this thing that you're
working on in the meantime
becomes a money waster and you go into
debt good do you have any do you have
any skip I got it
do you have any I got it you have any
sense of how to make this successful
right now I have support from Chris
gantry Pam Belfort
I've hit songwriters doing residency's
for free in my lounge promoting me is it
open now it's open for six months and
how's it going okay how unprofitable is
it how like how about in my last life
and how much are you losing each month
good yeah I got it that's right
and the only hardcore guaranteed cost
you have is the rent right like for real
for real Walker
yep get sit in my store okay I got it I
totally understand do you think this is
a foregone conclusion that it's not
gonna work out and it's a very serious
question because I think it's an
important important question I don't
know it's a very good fair answer
because the problem here is with that
short period of time 10 months surely
don't want you to start racking up
credit card bills or whatever else well
you know you you'll in my opinion only
have two paths you get on the offense
and speed up your burn by running
Instagram and Facebook ads and see if
you can drive local traffic or you start
right now getting out of it and seeing
if somebody will take it kind of over
and you keep five months of it that you
know you lose 15 more and somebody else
kind of takes over or whatever you work
out those are really your only two
options I genuinely believe that I think
you do you think of that thought and
again because I want to get to everybody
because I have a hard time on stage but
I mean this because I really mean it
feel free to email me and we'll can
continue the conversation but I really
think those are your two options and
that's okay it really is okay I can see
by the way and you know this you're
already there yeah so let's like gonna
do it smart instead of just going
through the motions and losing more
money for no reason makes sense it's
permission sometimes it's just
permission you already know it's black
and white to me you know and that's okay
and the fact that you're in a mental
plug I can tell you're okay with it
losing the biggest reason people hook up
is they're not okay with it losing in
front of other people's I either since I
can see
I can hand it off to somebody else for
nothing you can have it you take over
the rent probably a good conversation
okay we're trying to build after that as
the salesperson my first day I was
handed the catalogue fifteen years ago
and said go sell something so zero sales
training yes and then as a sales manager
it was virtually the same so I was just
a successful salesperson escalated sales
management habits all time no training
right habits all time can I get anything
happens all time so for me it's it's I
have these experiences that have given
me struggling moments yep you know and I
have empathy for those moments in
everybody else's life and I think in the
sales world that affects two things your
psychology as the seller you know and
then the cycle and in time to be is the
foundation of the most successful
salespeople in the world makes a ton of
sense I didn't name it my wine that for
fun like nope I totally understand your
reverse engineering yeah you know when
you said put yourself in my shoes
like and the reason I jumped in I was
like that's the only thing I know how to
do I don't even live in my own shoes
which is which is my vulnerability
because they'd he get taken for granted
and my the things that I struggle with
my surroundings is that it's the reverse
you get taken for granted when you only
live in everybody else's shoes when are
you there for yourself
that's my shortcoming but it's very
attractive to everybody else so I
understand keep going
learn now as an executive is to
understand what the mind of buyer looks
like in terms of sitting around the
table like this and I think there's a
big gap in the sales process
world thank you that way of course cuz
everybody wants to just shove it through
sheer numbers and push it's listening
not talking yeah exactly yep so I was on
the ceiling I was on a sales call that
yesterday from a salesperson and they
wouldn't stop it was 29 minutes of them
talking and we got very little so
absolutely what I'm trying to do is
right now I'm a VP of a billion on
business and I've got that to do and
I've got this enterprise that I'd like
to build over time trying to be patient
are you able to put out content without
it being a vulnerability to your main
job are you able to a sea of course
because perception is reality
you know Jesse's sitting right behind
you works for me he's worked for me for
six years is Jesse in a place where he
thinks he can put out tons of content
because he wants to start a small agency
vaynermedia like thing in my world the
answer is yes
you know like that's what I've kind of
tried to create and people have seen it
you know and it's still probably no to
all of them and Jesse I've known for a
long time since he was the most handsome
eighth grader in my brother's class so
so my so so my my hope my hope would be
that if that was his hopes and dreams
he'd reach out to me and try to make me
be a part of that journey but even that
even knowing him that long even him
being with my company so long I actually
think that would be a tough jump even
for him because people are always
struggling with if they're being selfish
within an organization does that
organization spit out that right but it
is the answer to your question and so
now the question becomes are you able to
actually do it or does the organization
view that as a selfish behavior that
makes you vulnerable in the short term
in your normal job that is the elephant
in the room and I would argue then
because it's a billion dollar company
maybe there is enough modern-day
thinking at the top or they realize
they're getting the benefit of it now
and and and by the way it is the right
look at it it just they may not look at
it that way but I think it's your only
answer otherwise you're in golden
handcuff mode you only got two moves you
do the content you know exactly what to
do
you just don't know if you can get away
with it or if it's appropriate I know so
I'm listening
you either my advice do it and every day
be prepared if it's not acceptable
anymore what am I gonna do taking a step
back financially and do a different job
or a lot of times they don't realize
that they're already in a position to
get all the same dollars right away you
might be able to have for consulting
gigs that you can have right away
but the answer is very clear and so I
think that what I would do is either you
have enough savings or you have your
exact moves you're gonna do the day they
say your real work here anymore that
even you go from 280 a year to 173 you
can survive and you can start this
process that is the answer make sense
it's a very practical yeah I mean really
it's the you know I'm trying to like add
on to it for value but like that's the
answer and honestly honestly I think it
will be okay but I think you can't hope
so what you should be spending time on
is building seven to ten relationships
of like hey this is where I'm going Ron
it was nice to meet you the Chamber of
Commerce so great to meet you three
years ago it was nice working with you
four years ago hey in five years I'm
gonna start my own firm and like would
you be a client be nice to have eight of
those then when it hits the fan three of
them actually come through you know you
always think like it's the same reason
every day think about my entire family
dying in a tragic accident I'm always
hedging on a thing I care about the most
right for you in the business life
you're always you know it's why I think
about if everything fails at Vayner and
everything else there's always still the
Gary B brand how vulnerable would it be
if I kept everything why would anybody
want to listen like I think about those
things oh well I could still sell on
eBay like really I'm not kidding like
you know every day you're four you know
I don't like being in the
right business yeah well that's a that's
a perspective that I've appreciated
about your content that I feel like
there needs to be a narrative around
that you're driving that narrative but
the executives or people with
specialized knowledge inside of
enterprises now who in putting that out
on social media and the idea that some
organizations
American capitalist companies love being
in capitalism but treat their employees
like communism I don't want to be a
hypocrite
I want Jesse to do what Caleb to do
whatever they want I'm proud that babban
is doing what he wants to do now I
wasn't happy to lose him
you know I don't want to lose anybody
good people who wants to but the
hypocrisy I can't I can't get there
CFO's LinkedIn content that brings CFO's
value of information not in the form of
it's a hidden sales pitch that's why it
was my opening sentence the end
teachers are coming to me I'm able to
help them
you're a counter-puncher by trade but
now you have to go and attack I
understand you don't by being a media
company so they come to you he did it he
used to go try to get everybody he's to
marketing then he just put out content
that was actually valuable and now he
can't stop them coming to him you need
to put out content for CFOs of
corporations that bring them value that
might have nothing to do with your
product and service you might start a
show a podcast called the CFO show and
you just interview people that bring
value to CFO's not do sales pitches and
that's how you have them come to you
right now I'm with high networks I
wouldn't throw a flea market and I'm
trying that's all it will always be
referral but the best way to attract the
initial base is disproportionately
bringing them value not in disguise as a
sales pitch
everybody says Gary Vee I'm doing what
you said I'm bringing value I'm like no
you're not the second I look at your
content you're perceiving to bring value
but you're actually being selfish
there's a lot of ways people a lot of
people like Gary first I'm gonna ask let
yesterday you know Austin and I carry
two questions one I'm gonna be selfless
one I'm gonna be selfish
they were both selfish Gary V I'm gonna
do a huge favor when you land in
Nashville I'm gonna drive you to your
hotel they're not gonna pick me up and
ask for a consulting session while I'm
exhausted
let me buy you dinner really you mean
get three hours of my time so you can
ask me all your questions which normally
cost $100,000 for what for an $86 dinner
you're not being selfless you're being
selfish people confused put out content
for CFOs on LinkedIn that bring them
value and have nothing to do with what
you're up to and watch how many come to
you with what you're up to
because just like I told him when they
see what you do in your profile they'll
say huh
which will work as a short-term tactic
and I like it I believe in that
what is disproportionately better in my
opinion is having it come to you well
there's a reason there's a reason
pretty girls have more options it comes
to them it's not super complicated this
is very real it makes it makes all the
sense of the world and I'm telling you
exactly how to replicate it and it
should and it's gonna come natural to
you because you've been a service you've
provided you just have to even what's
going through right now you're just okay
just got to look at it from that
perspective instead of this one I hate
selling I don't want to tell you I would
have all 30,000 cases of empathy sold if
I loved selling I'll just ask you I
don't like it I'll do it occasionally
I'll do it occasionally and I don't mind
throwing a right hook I just don't like
it right I don't love it you do you do
you didn't need to do it let me explain
why you need to do it I wrote a book
called jab - jab right hook not Jeff
Jeff Jeff Jeff jab you do need to do it
you do need to do it because think about
how many of you have not bought empathy
and buy other wine it's fine but notice
how my sentence was deployed not you
didn't buy empathy you didn't buy
empathy and you buy other wine you will
go to Albertsons or specs or whatever
your store is and buy other wine but all
the ridiculous value I've brought you
has not compelled you enough to buy it
that's why you have to throw right hooks
if you want to be in business but that's
okay
I get it I get it there's a million
things but you can imagine and it's a
very narrow thing like I have provided
more value than the thirty thousand
cases it should have been a layup but
it's not even remotely close to there
because that's how actually it works and
that's ok that's what's amazing about
giving without expectations you have
zero hurt from that put out content for
CFOs on LinkedIn your business will
thrive you can you can hit them up I
have no idea what's gonna happen but you
can definitely hit them up but I'm
telling you right now as somebody who's
been to the counterpunch business you're
better to create another framework of
counterpunching versus attacking your
Floyd Mayweather you're not Mike Tyson
so you can go try to be Mike Tyson with
Allen
you can go stop in that what's gonna
happen is gonna be the most important
part right guys this is very basic
there's too much value and information
out there so you have to provide more
and more and more value to have a
differentiator supply and demand yep yep
you're gonna sound creeping sales into a
certain demo and you're not gonna feel
creepy and salesman to a certain demo
yeah
if you're not putting content out on
these a platform so you don't exist
there's nothing else to say that's the
world we now live in you got to put
around your subject at first it takes a
decade to get into a place where a piece
of Bieber and blueberries was my subject
I was making a point at the end which is
don't use lunch as an excuse to not work
can I say something real quick because I
think it's gonna help you and this is a
neat add own the fact that you're
selling something this is where
everybody gets hurt right like they're
caught they're not sure if they should
go to selling information or not right
they want to build something more
scalable it's right I understand right
you need to own it I'm I'm actually very
proud when I'm like hey buy my wine or
you know like for DS or like you know
like I'm fine with it
cuz I'm I'm proud of what I sell and I
need to own it and it doesn't make like
the reason I consistently even think
about the story I just told you I don't
expect you know everyone's you know
think about how people do [ __ ] think
about best practices in funnel
conversion right up to the punch line
and now you got to pay come on you know
what that is
it may convert better in the short term
you might sell 30,000 cases of wine
versus eight but I'm gonna buy the New
York Jets got it so just depends on what
you're up to it
sometimes you need short term dollars
maybe something bad happened and you own
a loanshark 400,000 you better then you
better close people right away
always always
but what struggles is when people go
into oh now I'm selling something they
immediately go into a short term
strategy because because the ROI is the
conversion you're playing in a
conversion based scheme now
in those all same places ironically this
is why it's such a great question I
appreciate it
chasing new hot thing for quick scores
is the people I'm talking about if you
believe cannabis is gonna win and I do
and you're really passionate about it
and you're interested in edibles healing
people like you're passionate about it
would I go all-in on that because that's
great blockchains gonna happen but if
they're going into blockchain to create
a fake cryptocurrency to do an IC o----
and make a quick eighty thousand
trillion dot got it these trends are
real social media was right the problem
with all the social media experts in
2011 is they weren't experts and they
were selling homes you know a year
earlier before that collapse and then
two years later they were selling sports
gambling cannabis sports betting
cryptocurrency eSports all of those
things are gonna happen because they've
already happened hey I oh those are all
real things that are gonna happen now
the question becomes are you good at it
all those things are good that you know
that's right like that's the point
that's that gets back to passion as not
fluffy as now practical I believe that
the greatest thing that's ever happened
is that we can all can do this I think
the worst thing that's ever happened is
we can all do this you're not competing
with everybody you're defeating with me
right so I believe the only way you can
win for real for real or the most
guaranteed framework is you're doing it
around something you love so much that
that's why you're up doing it at 11:30
at night because you love it so much
most people do things for the money they
don't love it and it's back to who I was
at school I had to do it and I didn't
love it which is why I didn't open a
single book for four years of high
school which is why it's failed so as
somebody who's lived both frameworks
it's not because somebody who actually
loves cannabis or sports betting or wine
or whatever is gonna destroy you because
she's gonna put more work and be better
at it more knowledgeable over time right
got it so all those things are gonna
work but this goes back to what do you
like best
now you have a skill set and were built
a company around a skill set that will
work for everything
which is great as somebody who has math
down you can then deploy that against
everything that's a micro version of why
I'm building vaynermedia vaynermedia is
in a real company it's a framework I can
use it against anything I can make you
the governor of Illinois with
vaynermedia in ten years I can attack
Crohn's disease cuz AJ has it I can
address I can scape I can do anything I
want so that's what you have a little
bit brewing right now which is cool you
have a skill set which is a very needed
skill set with just Qantas marketing on
the internet now where you become
vulnerable is so did people that knew
how to do Google back in a day and I
kept telling them to do social in there
like if this works and they got caught
as the attention goes away and things
change right math changes exactly
correct
so my my my intuition is that if you
sold something tangible that you nope
mm-hmm yep and around something you
loved the most that over time that would
be a disproportionately bigger business
than you selling the information of how
to do it I genuinely believe that so
something to be because you've already
thought through the other part right
deploying your talent against your own
thing around something you love is a
very interesting to be course I get it
because because you're in a b2b
framework it's the same reason she
thought she's now and they're Mike Tyson
business I'm like there's a way to stay
in the Floyd Mayweather business you're
just gonna be to be mine free yes that's
all this is can I hold on let me just
get I want I'm so scared to not get
through and it will wrap up
and so you know I have to find out
what's going really well I appreciate
the free content I just love your
intuition on it because the world does
not need more victims my you know when
someone's making an investment in my
program and I'm there designing a life
they're excited about living if I prove
that they're not victims I'm like yes
I'm gonna be there too a.m. if you need
to talk you know that type of thing
which are three content I just love your
intuition on that and so how do I avoid
creating more of like oh oh he heard he
was so bad to you oh you know that's not
what I do and it's really a how can you
stop being a victim and stop shutting
down your life and get to the next level
that comes but isn't that coming through
what you're actually doing yes so I see
my intuition is you're using that
ideological point of view to justify you
not doing it because you don't fully
believe in it that's my first hotcake
okay that you've decided putting out
free content just creates more
victimization instead of what I think it
does which is you're gonna be helping
people serendipitously without realizing
it and some percentage of them are gonna
go into your funnel and some are
actually not going to need to go into
your funnel and are gonna be cured just
from free content and that's amazing to
in my opinion well good news that's what
I think is happening you've decided that
the free content is an enabler of more
victimization so now all you need to do
is decide what I just said is more
aligned with the way you actually say it
I appreciate the way you just said that
that's exactly right
you decide
you're not gonna be able to control it
anyway it's back to the things that
people are passionate you're not in
control of that anyway you're you're 49
posts on Instagram are not gonna make a
blip on the radar of victimization what
is more likely as yoga roundly helped to
people without them ever going into your
funnel and that aligns with what you get
about that's what I'm doing right I give
advice I take right I'm helping a lot of
people who never give me a penny not a
sneaker not a book not a banner nothing
gets shared when it's a 100 percent 98
cuz it's a hundred got it so you know
what I mean you're gonna go through
you're about to go through exactly what
he and she went through you can start
putting it out you have more people in
the funnel than you could have ever
imagined and you're gonna have the
serendipity of somebody grabbing you in
the in the airport and saying thank you
you're gonna win you're gonna win twice
you're gonna win twice make sense we
live in a world where 95% of people's
framework is insecurity which only leads
to bad relationships I understand that
but you putting out content doesn't
enable more victimization I do not
believe that I could be wrong but you
get to decide of course
there's advantages and disadvantages of
the process ago some dough person it
it's a million it's that's why this
works totally it's cool
1,000 on YouTube yep I feel like like
positivity motivation and feel bad that
I'm like selling my change of me
I said let's I think what I'm trying to
do with the puddles so but I was
thinking should I monetize the podcast
but now after listening to you today I'm
like no no I mean whoever holds their
breath the longest wins my plane is to
hold my breath until I die
yeah you know like so that's it yeah the
ironic thing is while you're holding
your breath the thing you want to happen
is happening yeah without you
compromising putting your head on the
pillow yeah yeah fun it is for me
this is why I keep trying to teach
people how to build things that they
need financially that don't come at the
requirement of monetizing their audience
yeah and there's nothing wrong with
monetizing your audience and there's
nothing wrong with after you monetize
your audience if it doesn't feel good to
change back everything's in play and
everything changes every day
yeah economy collapses tomorrow
everyone's in deep and like maybe you
need the money maybe because you made a
million and it seemed so easy and like
wow this is incredible
maybe you were extending yourself maybe
I don't know I don't know if people go
out and buy like everyone does different
yeah so like the advice that this is
back to why these are fun for me it's
contextual this is easy now like these
are themes of things but like think
about all the moments it's like 92 like
I need to talk to get the because I
believe you actually I felt about like
okay you know as we kept on I'm like
okay but maybe this and that was it 98
so hundred looking at it where you can
replicate what you've done in the past
thinking about only be two because
that's been your whole career but
realizing wait a minute you could do b2c
because by the way if you build a
product that's the stuff that actually
sells for 400 million dollars is a
product like you know vitaminwater sells
to Pepsi
you know like L'Oreal buys that product
from you Pfizer buys that product from
you
Reles it's been working for 11 straight
years it's just inevitable now you know
yeah but then then it's fast timing you
know you just crash and burn yep yep I
get it almost I get it and like totally
change so my message is a lot like yours
like it's it's happiness all of this
stuff but that got some of the stuff but
if this isn't in together people that
come to my audience and what you what
you've got to decide is every time
you're monetizing the audience you're
losing credibility with them because
they feel like you did that to get the
money yeah by by selling something else
like by creating a different matter
sure I love that like guys we remember
watch what I do not what I say how many
people do you think I can sign up for a
$50,000 a year mastermind where I see
them four six times a year how many how
many how many how many how how many how
many bro number how many how many think
about that think about that so let's
talk about that and I'm found selling
wine and sneakers with the thought of if
you drink wine or if you want to buy it
to give gifts instead of some other both
gift certificate this holiday season if
you wear sneakers it's not even in the
realm financially of what I could be
doing that's my answer where it gets
really neat though why I love this
advice is I think we're about to live
through a explosion of brands with
people behind them and all of a sudden
this is why I'm pushing you so hard all
of a sudden if you do start a nail
polish because you love it I don't know
you like or toothpaste you know now
you're putting your head on your pillow
because for me it's really easy because
I know I want to give the information
for free yeah but I also know you brush
your teeth
yeah and I don't expect you because I
gave you great expectation to use mine
over crest now the whole cycle works got
it
I'm not monetizing the core thing I'm
giving you something that you already
are doing I'm not asking you buy a hula
hoop like you're wearing sneakers and
you're drinking wine or you're not
because you're recovering or you don't
wear sneakers and that's fine and if you
wear sneakers and I've do many people
email me things like you've you've
stopped me from suicide you've made me a
million dollars and then once in a blue
moon because I like learning I'm like
did you buy empathy they're like I'm not
yet because I need that information to
give advice here because I don't want to
send you down the wrong path like that's
that's you know but that's my that's
what I think you should do when you
don't feel great about it and you don't
feel great about it right this second my
way you could also take one year on one
year off you could you don't feel great
about it now you go in a different way
then you're like I miss the money and
need some money then you do it you can
do you want but let me promise you one
thing when you're monetizing your
audience they know
this do you have a division of gallery
and New York
yeah do you know what gallery is it's
what owns pure Wow and 137 does the
podcast yet your it's Gary intermedia
I'm happy to pass you to Mary who'd you
talk to Mary Kate Ryan okay okay yeah
thanks yep yep yep
it's so weird to have to release the
product still nervous about selling
something and then have your audience
thank you yeah the quotes of course best
feeling best but I also started out
doing this whole thing doing brand work
I've been doing brand work for four
years yeah but I love creating content
for brands yep this year I work for
Disney yeah my dream brand yes but now
I'm in this weird dynamic where I am a
brand but I'm also a brand influencer
quite I know but it's like I'm I'm all
over the place I feel like with my
energy both yeah oh yeah because we're
working I feel like I guess I'm trying
to think too far ahead of life now the
preset things working now I want to
release two ebooks that people ask me
constantly yep like for sorry I don't
know how to like do that and then you're
talking about a podcast which I would
love to do with a knack to little girls
yeah of course so it comes down to a
couple things leisure like like how much
or how little do you need it like is it
more fun for you to launch to ebooks and
do another thing for gap or is it more
fun for you to like escape for a little
bit and go ski or weep so then don't do
it so don't do it don't do it okay so
focus more of my biz
into it correct what people think is
they think things are absolutely I use
an analogy yesterday really worked for
me like just cuz you're just because the
other team went on a 13 Oh run in the
second quarter of the basketball game in
the home team booed you like the home
crowd booed you doesn't mean the game's
over
like just cuz you stopped doing brand
work doesn't mean that you're not
allowed to go back in they're not gonna
forget about you do you know what I mean
people think like something's going away
yeah brand work with influencers is
gonna continue in perpetuity but but
when you go through this process now of
monetizing two ebooks and this product
the stickiness and conversion base of
your audience will continue to decline
I know photography I know because
there's a breaking point it's like open
rates it's like anything it's like ads
on Instagram they worked better for it
three years ago than today of course I
know now if you're providing so much
value that the top of your funnel grows
so you have a million people you start
monetizing them at first it works the
second time less the third time less but
if you're going from a million of 3
million people because what you're doing
on the side if you can keep growing it
you don't see it but it's still
happening
you're like gary was wrong it did 2
million this year I'm like nope you grew
2x 2.9 X you're converting do you
understand and then the really scary
part is if another person comes up that
has enough similarities with you that
they siphon your audience cuz they're
not asking for anything do you know how
upset all the motivational marketers are
with me them up
that's the one group that's not happy
with me the $50,000 mastermind but you
know the reality is there's still so
many people so that's what I think look
look
you've already lived the advice like
hold your breath it's always the same
answer that's awesome it's awesome
that's great that's awesome hold your
breath it just always works guys provide
more value than you're asking for in
return it's as basic as it gets plenty
of you know passion Jesus and like in
the set like it's the answer it's hard
people and don't make pretend you're
doing it that's what a lot of people are
doing in this room and in the world
don't make pretend you're doing it don't
justify why you're not doing it it's a
very simple thing cuz it's convenient
for what you want right now and that's
fine that's human I do that too doesn't
mean it's not true thank you yeah you've
recently felt the entire impact of this
entire thesis and honestly just the
happiness that I've had this past three
or four months has been leaps and bounds
as opposed to thinking about marketing
constantly and new ad why this ad isn't
working anymore it was just a big yeah
the email from the CFO and your LinkedIn
is like thank you for putting that out
about why I should be investing more in
PR you know versus you getting an email
saying take me off your unsubscribe list
you're spamming me from the same human
that's the difference between putting
out value or trying to monetize that's
it simple is simple you know what you
guys would hate me if I went the other
way because I'd be good at it I'm good
at selling I'm really good at it you
would hate me you would've bought
something I would split more wine I mean
it
you know you know yes we did they did
that into the yesterday so I've been
thinking a lot about just like you said
what makes you happy
yes honestly I have that you know the
end of your video I be happy that rings
in my head good time and I've been just
doing that evaluating and I've kind of
realized that like I like doing my
adjustments I love my patience but I
really love doing lectures and videos
and like when people get it I get it in
just I've had people come in like oh
email me or call me a year later like I
was at one of your diabetes seminars and
like just listen to the nutritional
advice you gave and like I don't have
diabetes I'm not on blood pressure
cholesterol and I love that never paid
me a dime right like I get it free
lectures so I'm realizing that I want to
do more of that and eventually kind of
phase into that realm great right so I'm
trying to build my brand more right now
primarily in my whole audience like my
life lines been face book and you can't
allow that I don't know you need to fix
that yes but you can't don't try on
every single different thing you like
build my youtube and all of it and do
all of that so that's the amount of
people they're gonna get hurt when
Instagram or get changes is gonna be
devastated right and that's what I don't
want and I've done I do a radio show as
well great in the city so you know I
have diversified and I'm getting you
know pretty pretty popular so I'm trying
to build those other platforms I guess
my question is like how do I
or when do I start targeting like I
guess greater than the city because I'm
getting popular in the city like I
wanted you know like that will naturally
that's gonna actually happen
that's what's so beauty about social
media marketing just cuz you're
targeting Ottawa doesn't mean one person
doesn't share it and California doesn't
think that's naturally I've had that of
course videos the answer the answer to
your question the answer to your
question is more of the same just keep
when didn't you go from man to brand I
did it I'm still doing more of the same
it just feels like I did because of the
level of success I literally do the same
I did 10 years ago
I'm just curious too because I want to
get like constantly get the same
questions that's why I made the videos
in the first place I was getting the
same questions over and I'm like I'm
just going to shoot a video I think I
think you're my personal point of view
quick fake is your where she was when we
met two years ago and I just wait so
wait so just put your head down and like
like put your head down and do another
two years of this and then come back up
for air and debate it again all of this
will be here unless you die it's all
gonna be here writing books will be here
television shows will be here like all
this will be here the Internet's won and
the internet needs content no you need
to squeeze it for all it is right now
and you need to siphon that information
to your own email newsletter your own
text messaging platform you need to win
a LinkedIn you need to win on podcast
you need to do everything everything
everything
it's scary because you're
disproportionately over-leveraged there
everything's scary of course it's a
matter of time we've been you could
watch it happen for the last decade
myspace was number one
Dane Cook came from there Tila Tequila
came from there definitely not it just
it doesn't cuz it's not built to be able
to do if we're not capable it we're not
capable like the minimum fee for
vaynermedia is a million dollars but
Sasha group might be able to so you're
not burning no no you're losing money
you're burning that means you're burning
that means you're burning yeah you're
burning but still burning breakeven good
well then that's different yeah then you
start going on the office that makes I
don't want to die I agree a bad idea
all right I gotta go snake stage can we
get quick pictures or let's go fast
you